>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> I'm Jane McAuliffe.
I'm the director of National
and International Outreach here
at the Library of Congress and the
Poetry and Literature Center falls
under part of our national
and international outreach
and I'm delighted to
be able to welcome you
to this afternoon's event
celebrating our new Witter
Bynner Fellow.
Let me say a word or two
about the fellowship itself.
It's a program by which the
library's Poet Laureate consultant
in poetry selects one or two
poets to organize a reading
in their home states and then
to travel here and participate
in an event and a recording session.
We have a pretty illustrious
list of previous fellows
in this position including
Heather McHugh
who was a MacArthur
Foundation awardee,
the Pulitzer Prize winner
Claudia Emerson and Carl Phillips
who was an Academy of
American Poets Chancellor.
Our new fellow Allison Hedge Coke
is a wonderful addition to that list
and to this fellowship and we
look forward to hearing her read
and to participate in a moderated
discussion here this afternoon.
Also later this spring on April
28th she will give her State reading
in conjunction with the Oklahoma
State Center for the Book.
The 21st Poet Laureate Consultant in
Poetry Juan Felipe Herrera is here
to introduce Allison
Hedge Coke to you.
Juan Felipe has added
immeasurably to the Laureate ship
with his tireless travels
across the country
and his online project
La Casa de Colores.
Thank you, thank you very much
Juan Felipe for breathing new life
into this position's historic role.
I also want to thank the
Witter Bynner Foundation
and its executive director,
Steven Schwartz
because the support
they have provided
for this wonderful
fellowship is so important
to the Library of Congress.
Mr. Bynner, the namesake
of the foundation was himself an
influential, early 20th century poet
and translator and this fellowship
continues his work and that
of the foundation to
perpetuate the art of poetry
and to expand awareness of
the very positive effect
that it has on society.
And finally a word about the
Library of Congress which is,
as I think many of you know,
the nation's first federal
cultural institution
and the largest library
in the world.
Our mission quite simply is to
promote knowledge and creativity
for the benefit of the
American people and programs
like this one really
embody that mission.
The library is a home for
literature in so many ways
with our historic readings,
with books, audio recordings,
a wealth of manuscript collections,
collections that also
include the works
of outstanding American
novelists and innovative poets
such as Walt Whitman, Langston
Hughes, Gwendolyn Brooks
and Muriel Rukeyser
among many, many others.
Of course you could find
all this on our website.
I urge you to go to the Library of
Congress website and particularly
to the site of the Poetry and
Literature Center which has worked
for almost 80 years to foster and
enhance the public's appreciation
of poetry and literature under
particularly the direction
of our consultant Poet Laureate.
You know this is the only
federally-mandated position
for a literary writer and we're
very, very fortunate to have
that housed within the Library
of Congress and now I would
like to welcome our Poet
Laureate to the stage, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> [Inaudible] thank
you, thank you so much,
it's an honor to be here once
again to see good friends
that I met recently within
the year as Poet Laureate
of the United States and
once again I'm very humbled
to be in this position.
It's such an amazing role,
a magnificent role to travel
around the United States and
to speak to so many audiences,
to meet so many inspired human
beings, to meet so many people
that love poetry and literature and
books at book signings and to listen
to poetry and also to write poetry.
I've met five-year-olds,
11-year-olds,
fathers who bring their children
to meet me at the signing table
and they say, son or daughter,
I want you to meet a poet.
I want you to meet a writer.
I want you to meet the Poet
Laureate of the United States.
And their child is there
and they go, oh hello,
hello and we shake
hands, so it is like that
and young teachers, young teachers.
I just started my teaching
this year, they tell me and I'm
so excited that we have
poetry that we can use
and thank you so much for writing.
So then I meet the new teachers,
brand new ready to venture
out to the school to teach and
that is how I also met Allison,
Allison Hedge Coke, teaching in
Vermont and she was getting her MFA.
This is the 90s and I
noticed what a talent she was
and I noticed her deep insight
into things, things that some
of us may not have seen, things
that we have seen and maybe kept
on driving or walking or just
didn't take notice that they
and maybe the next day we did.
Perhaps they were tractors.
Perhaps they were tobacco leaves
or perhaps they were just workers
sweating in the fields working away,
living their lives under that
harsh sun and women covered
in whatever they could put on to
protect themselves from pesticides
and that hard work that we all
value and yet sometimes we don't see
in books or poetry books.
And it's not there for us at times,
and yet Allison has taken the time
to notice that as a worker in
those particular tobacco fields
as a worker and those barns where
the tobacco is tied up and hung
up to dry under flames
and heaters and burners.
She knows that world and it's
the same perhaps in her poetry
where she burns and
where she lifts things up
and where she unravels leaves,
leaves of time, leaves of family,
leaves of workers and perhaps
leaves of consciousness.
And it's a beautiful work.
It's a very compassionate work.
And I just enjoy it so much because
I notice the colors and I want
to get on those tractors.
I see those tractors in the
morning, you know painted by dawn.
I see those fields the way my father
must have seen them in Cheyanne,
Wyoming in the early
1900s when we first worked
in the United States from Mexico.
So there are many landscapes
and also internal landscapes
as Denise Levertov said 'the
outscape' and 'the inscape'
and we have both with
Allison Hedge Coke.
We go out there and we also go
inside and she does it in a keen set
of translations and with
beauty, with great choreography
and with a beautiful voice you
know and I just enjoy the moments
and the materials in her poems
and for me that is good enough.
Of course there is
much more going on.
We were talking this
morning about her horses.
She has a mustang called Spirit that
she has on a 10-acre piece of land
in Oklahoma and then she has
another horse called Sister that's a
Medicine Cap horse, a warhorse
and she has a little house made
out of rocks and that, where
she lives and I find that,
you know kind of the
way, the way to live.
How can I tell you?
The way to live, I remember my
own parents' little trailers
and that my father made with
whatever wood he could find,
built on top of a chassis of a
[inaudible] car that he managed
to put all together like a puzzle
and it was a very simple life,
a life of simplicity and also a life
of warmth, storytelling and of love.
And this is what's all in,
for me, in Allison's work
and she has a big voice,
you know she's been writing
for decades as you know.
I made a note of some of the things.
I know that she has seven
books and I'm just going
to mention a couple of them for you.
"Streaming" is her most recent
one, Coffee House Press 2014.
And next she has another,
"Rock, Ghost, Willow,
Deer" and that's a Bison
Books 2014 and "Blood Run"
by Earthworks Series,
Salt Publishing 2007
and "Off-Season City Pipe" and
that's the one, that's the sort
of poems that I remember seeing
for her MFA thesis I believe
from "Off-Season City Pipe".
And you could run into those
fields and those tractors
and you feel them turn on and
the engines at dawn and the rain
and the fire in the
burning of the barns
and the small granules
and the pigsty.
And I encourage you to read them and
enjoy them and ride that tractor.
She has many awards you know,
lists and lists of awards
and let me just mention
the Pen Southwest Award,
the Lifetime Achievement Award for
a Native writer from the Circle
of the Americas, Native
Writer Circle of the Americas
and also the Endowed
Chair in Creative Writing,
the Distinguished Paul W.
Reynolds and Clarice Kingston Chair
at the University of Nebraska.
And of course she writes in
various journals you know, poetry,
creative non-fiction, song,
lyric and critical essay.
And this list ends with this
note, her mom put her poems
in a cedar chest when she was a
child and back in the middle school
and did you ever get
those poems back?
And she got those poems back.
>> We found them when she passed.
>> So she found them, we found
them when her mom passed away
so this is how deep and how
beautiful and how meaningful poetry
for many a decade and many a working
field under the scorching sun
and the scorching pen has
been for Allison Hedge Coke.
Let's give her a beautiful hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you all for coming
out, it's a real honor for which
to be here especially
with Juan Felipe.
I'm just so happy that
he's here for the country,
thank you Juan Felipe, thank you.
It's a huge honor.
I'm going to start
with "The Change",
Looking for Anya [phonetic],
okay, "The Change".
"Thirteen years ago
before bulk barns
and fifth-gear diesel tractors we
rode royal blue tractors big enough
to hold a six-pack on ice.
In the one hundred and fifteen
degree summer heat with air so thick
with moisture you drink
as you breathe.
Before the years that
dusters sprayed malathion
over our clustered bodies.
We perspire while we prime the
bottom lugs those ground-level
leaves of tobacco and they
clung to us with a black tar
so sticky we rolled eight-inch
balls off our arms at night
and Cloroxed our clothes
for hours and hours."
"Before we were poisoned and the
hospital thought we had been burned
in fires at least to the third
degree when the raw oozing hives
that covered ninety-eight percent of
our bodies from the sprays ordered
by the FDA and spread
by the landowners before anyone
had seen the automated machines
that top and prime.
We topped the lavender
blooms of many tiny flowers.
The blooms gathered
into one, gorgeous.
By grasping hold below the petals
with our bare, calloused hands
and twisting downward quick, hard
only one time snapped them off."
"Before edgers and herbicides took
what they called weeds we walked
for days through thirty acres and
we chopped them out with hoes.
Hoes made long before from
wood and steel and sometimes,
even longer ago, from
wood and deer scapula.
Before the bulk primers came we
primed all the leaves by hand,
stooped over at the
waist for the lower ones
and through the season gradually
rising higher until we stood
and worked simultaneously as
married to the fields as we were
to each other, carrying up to
fifty pounds of fresh leaves
under each arm and sewing them on
to sticks four foot long on a looper
under the shade of a
tin-roofed barn made of shingle."
"To be caught by a hanger who
poked it up higher in the rafters
to another who held an
even higher position
and so they filled the barn.
And the leaves hung down
like butterfly wings
so sometimes the color of lunar
moths or Carolina parakeets
when just an hour go they had
been laid upon the old wooden cart
trailers pulled behind the
orange Allis-Chalmers tractor
with huge round fenders and
only a screwdriver and salt
in the toolbox picked by primers so
hot we would race through the rows
to reach the twenty-five gallon jugs
of water placed throughout the field
to encourage and to satisfy our
insatiable thirst from drinking air
which poured through our pores
without breaking through to our need
for more water in the sun."
"The sun we imagined to
disappear and yet respected
for growing all things on earth when
quenched with rains called forth
by our song and drumming.
And leaves which weeks later will
be taken down and the strings pulled
like string on top of a large
dog-food bag and sheeted
up into burlap sheets and smashed
down with our feet and bundled
over the hundred pounds and gently
smashing them thrown up high
to a catcher on a big
clapboard-trailer
and pulled behind two-ton trucks
and taken to market in Fuquay-Varina
and sold to Philip
Morris and Winston Salem
for around a buck a pound."
"The leaves were cured to a
bright leaf, a golden yellow
with the strongest aroma
of our tobacco barn curing
and the hand-grown quality before
the encroachment of the big business
in the Reagan era and the
slow murder of our method
from a hundred years before.
When the loons cried out
in laughter by the pond
and the bass popped the surface
early on next to the fields before
that time when it was
unfashionable to transplant each,
individual baby plant the
infant tobacco that we nurtured
to transplant those seedlings to
each hill in the field a space
for that particular plant and
we watched as they would grow."
"Before all of this new way I was
a sharecropper in Willow Springs,
North Carolina as were you.
We were proud and would make camp
in winter and be free of tourists
and filled with snow and those
of us who held out forever
with our people would be home again.
Remembered before Europeans
worked shoulder to shoulder
with descendants of slaves that
they had brought from Africa
and they sold ancestors as
slaves into the Middle East,
that the tobacco was sacred to
all the people and all of us
and we prayed when we smoked
and did not smoke for pleasure
and I was content and free."
"And then they came and changed
things and you left me for a fancy,
whiter girl and I waited on our
land until you brought her back
in that brand new white
Trans Am purchased
from our crop you gave her,
left her waiting in a motel.
The nearest one was forty miles
away but it was near enough for you
and for her and I knew though I
never spoke a word to you about it,
I knew I kept it to myself until
this day and time and I never let
on until I left you
on our anniversary."
"I drove the pickup down the
dirt path by the empty fields
and I rented a shack for eighty
dollars one with cardboard windows
and a Gillespie house floor design
and torn and faded floral paper
on the walls and linoleum
so thin over the rotted wood
that the floor gave if you
weighed a hundred pounds.
And then I did not and with
no running water of any kind
or bathroom, the one at
hilltop where I could see
out across all the
fields and hunt for meat
when I wanted and find peace.
I heard you remarried and went
into automated farming and kept
up with America and I watched all
of you from the hill and waited
for the lavender blooms to
return when it was spring
and even the blooms
had turned white."
"So I rolled up my
bedroll remembering before
when the fields were like waves on
a green ocean and I turned away,
away from the change and corruption
of big business on small farms
and of traditional agricultural
people and sharecroppers.
Away so I could hold out of this
concise image of before that time
and it floods my memory."
[ Applause ]
I'll switch to a different
book, thank you.
This is [inaudible] on Me.
My sister is in the audience.
I want to give a shout-out to
my sister Stephanie Hedge Coke.
[ Applause ]
[Inaudible] "Mornings
made delirious scrambling
into thread out from dreaming.
We were rambling ways past delusion
into streets unpaved,
unproven and unmet.
It was a hard over no sunnyside easy
and the only yolk was seeded sky.
The rows was streaming over
the lot of us quickened
in some strain no corona could
bear resting into the lien.
Then the mesa set standing wayside
in case some giant made its way back
into the mean time and
met us here, met us."
"We were tabooed, shunned,
mocked and on our nettle most any
pierced day the principal struck
blows to show that
we deserved no mercy.
They were splintering, the hose
bore blisters every smacking wave
but we were deserving,
wave after wave
in first grade took
the test out of me.
I never did spill again
no matter the syndrome.
We were anything but beggars though.
We were scraping up and held up.
We'd flown ourselves into every
angle and withheld our curve."
"We split loose from
whatever held on to us
and Motown made our
mercy in those days.
Only sooth was in Western
[inaudible] rounded
up in radio waves cleaning out in
the insides of the maternal mind,
firing, unkind charge, firing
synapse beyond her reasoning goal.
She moved through it like lightning.
The madness charging each wave
with a serious challenge but never
and nothing made it
bearable and hands
down was just a game
that we called Brad."
"The only hands-down we laid was
on ball courts home
front the daily challenge
and there was nothing certain other
than every day would
be just like that.
At least they move you and sent
you off fostering again, someone,
no one warned you, might
[inaudible] sent you streaming,
gave you up like paper, tossed
and crumpled, straightened out
and smoothed out flat
and that was that.
It was nothing you'd
remember but we still do.
We do. We still taste that
strangeness surrounding ones who go
between and move through the
other worlds while in this one."
"No one lives like we
did, least it seems so.
We were always in the mind, on the
mind and why there was never time
to question and we still don't know.
The only thing we do know is that
we were different and not like you
and even though we might try three
times harder it never works right.
Nothing takes the sting of it
or our scent even we
look off, we sound off.
We give a presence everyone
knows stay away and they do.
So far from us we walk
sideways in vanishing points.
We turn to the horizon soaking
our sin and distinguishing us,
metal in our mouths as well.
It's steely and steel we did.
We still do.
No one's got no more lift."
"Remember that breakfast, the real
one over at the Pancake House off
of forty, dad took us there this
Christmas right before seeing her
off to the pavilion, the asylum.
The little dish of butter looked
like ice cream to us kids.
It made the eggs slide
over really easy just
like he did before the madness.
Man this is rough country,
get that straight.
Metal this."
[ Applause ]
I'm going to bring
some geniuses here
and we'll have a little bit of fun.
I'm a huge fan of both the new
musicians that are coming up,
Kelvyn Bell, guitars, composer,
[inaudible], of a funk jazz band,
a program director for Glauster
[phonetic] Arts Project.
Kelvyn Bell, will you
join me please?
It's Kelvyn, give him a round.
[ Applause ]
And Laura Ortman, I'm so pleased.
Laura [inaudible] instrumentalist,
composer and artist,
White Mouth Apache from Arizona,
she has lived in Brooklyn since 1997
and is a licensed and
really wonderful hairstylist
in New York City.
[ Applause ]
We're going to be performing a
couple of parts out of [inaudible].
It's a 30-some-page poem and we're
going to read the second section
and the fourth section which are
both on the CD we did together.
Coffee House Press was kind
enough to put me in the studio
and they bring in musicians
of my choice
and these are definitely my choice
and yeah you guys are going to be
in for a real treat, okay so.
[ Music ]
"We're still missing one
hundred and twenty-five head
from the Rock House fire.
There's seventy-four from
the least poor farmland.
The neighbors are keeping
a lookout, there's nothing.
The [inaudible] are torched
up like marshmallow rows.
They give [inaudible] of lips
curled quick in the heat.
There's twenty-nine special rangers
seeking out the rest in the fire
and anything loose is made clean
of herds, rustlers must be.
No vultures vortex to slide
overhead and no buzzards,
contours only smoke belies."
[ Music ]
"Downtown some flyers
offer reward next to a mom
and pop chiding their eldest
over dropping lit [inaudible]
into pathways.
There's no room for accidents
and no country for old men.
There's no room for it where
Woody wore belts decked
out by Grayville [phonetic]
by moonlight's best gemstone
and [inaudible] agate and too bad
the Shaws [phonetic] didn't display
the cut of them, real beauties
over sterling silver plate
and now the heat plates on the low
profile sports cars are tendering
the prairie grass ignition
cactus wrath anything is
at risk, everything is to blame."
[ Music ]
"Flames follow wind the way that
water follows wave over the seabed.
The ground is pummeling high
[inaudible] high, elevation as sure
as Denver but this
is a desert scene.
There's Chihuahua and [inaudible]
and now both are carrying
the largest wildfires
in colonial history.
Both are heeded harder
spreading further than pictured
in recent times and everything
from Tucson to Texas is rage."
[ Music ]
"Ladybird's roadside
flowers are billowing dust.
Chocolate flowers are still scenting
the straight paths familiar.
It is the fury fell, every
angle fuming hopping the asphalt
and by the time Gage
Holland [phonetic] breaks
from the roadside rest area
Highway ninety is shutdown clean
to Martha [assumed spelling] and
no one there holds much hope.
The rock house is said
to still be smoldering.
It's all without mercy
and without peace.
[ Music ]
"Dreams come easily branded
but no iron rod season
is coming this round.
We come easily into
infused [inaudible] games.
Our forearms are stubbed.
The spoons are cooked in
dosage blues and we shoot burn,
shoot up euphoria, the hero
flying through a blistered sky,
they called it a horse
in [inaudible]
and now the horses are shot
down, burned nine of them.
The nerves so frayed tea
kettle copper melts to blue
and then white ash
covers the electric burner
on the stove range while the range
outside roars, spats sideways
on to roofs, roads and branches."
[ Music ]
"The population is too sparse
here for a national concern.
They inspire no public radio
does spare lives nearby maybe,
maybe our own.
A measly thrill, a bitter, bitter
thing and cover [inaudible]
but damn it, they do
deserve some attention."
"We depend on them.
The announcers give them some glory.
We'll share in it, our same face,
the border patrol, the walk-in,
all right now in this
fire, a phoenix rise
and nothing shares the grace here.
A black field crust everything
and surviving is our only reason.
Look at it, gone.
There's no fire climax pines
to justify so much loss
and rebirth here is a fought thing.
Mr. Spanish was buried ceremonially
in a shoebox under glory flagpoles,
each nina entering
[foreign language spoken]."
[ Music ]
"Char [phonetic] rounds out
horizon now, it used to be shadows.
There were tall men in
saddles shifting through
and now shadow men unsaddle blow
away and wind on a giant [inaudible]
with secrets and untold
shutter of what should be proper
and what should be here is gone.
Char [phonetic] brings looseness,
it holds our memory intangible.
It blackens the earth in its own
beauty, not hollow but kept here.
In the evening the vultures
scan space and seek remnant,
the passing cranes feast on roasted
grasshoppers, crickets, larvae,
in mourning phoenix rises
through the community side opened
to opportunity lamenting and
we come here hoping for more,
knowing nothing surprises those
who present hope and what is hope?
Field of fortune, opportunity,
is it graced?"
[ Music ]
"In the meantime I'll wade through
ashes in a place ash turned to stone
when volcanoes came
up from the sea floor.
It's now a high desert what's
left of it, this caldera we're
in where putting down the
suffering is now our day's work.
We put down the beloved
and the betrothed burned.
Horses, cattle, goats, the
chickens they hold a roost
with their burned legs,
they go as well
to our wayside memory now asunder,
memory like the [foreign language
spoken] skipping in and out
and walking upward and falling,
the bird fountain motion moving.
We were born here someone mentions."
[ Music ]
"We don't know when fire was
still when the embers left
in themselves nor when rain will
visit or come to renew us now,
to free us from the burn, the danger
and nor do we know what cause this
in, the timing of a heat plate
on low grass, the nearness of grass
to blade in sunlight in the year
of the drought though some
speculate larger cycles surround
about here is intangible and nor
do we offer up ideas unless applied
with cold lager in the heat
here or in the evenings laid
out under the fiery
stars still gleaming
down always lighting the pathways we
lean toward in our nighttime escape
to the towns down the road
and no, we don't know.
All we know is we are not alone and
yet we are and everything is subject
to fire even the water
leaves and heated paths
and what we don't know we don't
search for nor do we attempt
to understand, no we deal with it.
We muster."
[ Music ]
"We move through the crust
salvaging pieces now,
we've become the salvagers.
We move through the heat
lifting a recognizable source,
lifting our permanence
from a tempered time,
we're lifting our home
now, our homes.
We tote the burned wire curled
into sphere like a story
and we surround light with it.
We harness the energy and plug it
in until the spherical globes
rekindle [inaudible] fires once
surrounding the livestock
and now bordering glow.
It is the strand we
feel, the obligation.
We're remaking stuff from cinder.
We're remaking."
[ Music ]
"Remaking, twins we
carry and then laid,
one light, one fire, do they rest?
Do they feel our burden, the
melting iron, wire, shifting wind,
funneling across prairie and
winding plumes, are they turning?
And what of the way that we embraced
to conceive them, we held them there
like satchels beaded in Cedar
Spring holding the floral burst
and dense trees, hills, waterways
that we come from, they kneel there,
now buried and when we bury bring
them gifts, make them offerings."
[ Music ]
"In the burn of your brow when
you hastened did you think before
belting me?
Did you conceive that intent?
What were you but burning?
[ Music ]
"Yet fire is the birth of life
and the spark there and we were
with the spark when ignited.
My life emptied into
the banks below, below,
they lie there now within mounds.
They were within me and now within
our Mother and I sometimes long
to lie there but I too mustered.
You, long gone to other
worlds not over there
but a wandering spark burn."
[ Applause ]
Laura Ortman, Kelvyn Bell.
Magic happening here, thank you.
Sure, I'm ready [laughter].
Thank you all for listening,
thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> That was beautiful.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Hello everyone, I'm Rob
Casper, the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center here
at the Library of Congress
and before we get to the
awarding of the fellowship
to Allison Hedge Coke I'm going
to take the opportunity just
to ask a few questions of Allison
and Juan Felipe but first I want
to thank you again Allison
for an amazing performance
and to our musicians for coming
here from New York to rock it.
[ Applause ]
I wanted to talk about, it's on?
I want to talk a little bit
about the power of performance.
It was interesting to see how in
that musical performance you kind
of played off of each
other, the musicians and you
but of course there are all sorts
of ways to use music and song
to empower poetry and I wanted you
to talk a little about the ways
that you both have done
that and seen that work.
>> Well you know I also have seen
Allison do a performance work
as well as give feedback to,
you know performance of writers
and writers that want
to be in performance
and I really noticed how
she responded many a time
and they were very, really
keen responses on how to do,
how to take your work
and put it into motion.
And I really enjoyed your responses
because they were really kind
of things that Allison said
were the kind of things
that you know a writer wants to
know what to do with that poem
and make it move on the
stage or how to go about it
and I thought that was amazing.
And as I was hearing
the great, fabulous,
magnificent musicians I
thought about the kind of work
that Allison does as a person
who encourages translations
of the First Peoples
throughout the United States
and throughout the entire hemisphere
and you know she has translated,
she has led projects and
anthologies with translations
of many indigenous peoples
throughout the entire hemisphere,
an amazing task and I'm
glad you asked that question
because I can bring it up.
And in a sense that's
what this is in a way.
When we hear the music
we hear the sounds.
We hear the shrieks.
We hear the riffs.
We hear the harmonies, the
[inaudible] harmonies and they kind
of go back and they really
go deep and that's one
of your concerns I think.
I think that's one of Allison's
concerns in the writing [inaudible].
>> Yes?
>> Yeah, I want to thank
Juan Felipe publicly as well
because he was one
of the translators.
He translated [inaudible] from
Columbia and so he was part
of the Project Sing
[assumed spelling] which was
about 86 poets that we had.
It's multilingual, there's a lot
of different languages and some
of them also could get the
[inaudible] and Spanish as close
as they could and then of
course bringing in somebody
like Juan Felipe, a genius
over here [laughter] to bring
that to our tables, to bring
that to somewhere we could sit
with the work no matter where people
are situated and hear that voice.
So it's a phenomenal honor to
be able to bring those people
to the audience and publish
that in the U.S. and as far
as I know it's the first time
it's ever been done and we did
that together in a way,
yeah so, yeah and a lot
of them are also performers you know
because poetry has those
older histories with oratories
with performance, with theaters
you know if you will but also just
so you could remember the lines you
know, there has to be musicality
and a lot of people
with their instruments.
You got lyrics from that
right so it's all connected
in that way to performance I think.
>> Well I listen to you
read and listen to the sort
of powerful rhythms of your poems I
thought a lot about capaciousness,
about the possibility for what
a poem can contain and the kind
of multitudes it can contain and I
wanted to ask you both about doing
that in a poem but also
shaping that in a poem.
I was struck by how your poem
is built up through rhythm
and theme especially imagery, a kind
of force that it then kind of worked
out in a magical and
mysterious and surprising way.
So maybe both of you could
just talk about that in your?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Yeah, a lot of the poetry comes
to me as music in my head and I have
to seek the words for it and
there's always some matter
of finding some balance for
tragedies that the memory invokes
that [inaudible] invokes and finding
a way to remake that, to flip it
and to turn something so that
there's a balance, a harmony reached
to some degree and yet we
still know the disaster,
we still have the tragedy and we
understand the realness of it.
So the strategy then becomes
working for an arc that allows
that trajectory to build so
that the change can exist
and [inaudible] pieces right?
It's that same process
it's just a longer piece.
I'm known for writing long poems
because I think in more of a,
sort of an epic narrative
whenever I'm reaching into ideas.
I hope that's helpful?
>> I heard people really
responding to that first poem.
I heard the audience really enjoying
that, your first poem about working
as a sharecropper,
working a sharecropper life
and I heard the routine and the
audience really respond to that
and all that, all those details,
kind of the muscularity of
and the tenderness of
it all at the same time.
You know the images, I don't know
you know, for me images are key
and it took me a while to get to
leave images but then I sneaked back
into image-land and I grabbed
those images again because they say
so much and what is the
world without images
and a mind without images?
So, for example Einstein right,
he was trying to work on,
Einstein was trying to work on
that great Theory of Relativity
and he got stumped at one point.
What was it 1907 around there?
And he [inaudible] I
can't get it right.
I've got the Theory of
Relativity, it's almost done
but I'm missing something.
What could it be?
And then he said I'm just
going to step out of the room.
I'll step out of the room and
go out here and I'm just going
to let my mind go, you know just
going to let it go, see what goes,
now I'm very much like what
we do right, artists do
and musicians do, all
of us and poets.
So he [inaudible] imagine, I want
to get out of this chalkboard room
and I'm going to imagine,
going to step up and I'm going
to imagine an elevator flowing
through space and then it goes shoo
and I'm [inaudible] somebody in
the shoo and it's floating all
of a sudden because of the
forces of gravity, shoo.
So all of a sudden he's
working with a notion
of acceleration and gravity.
So he goes what else can I do
here in my little poetic moment?
I'm going to drill a
hole through the elevator
and shoot a beam of
light through it.
Okay, now what is going
into infinite space?
[Inaudible] floating body
acceleration, gravity okay,
there's one more move
I've got to do.
Let's see what could it be?
I'm going to shoot a flashlight,
a light beam through
those little two holes
in the elevator and it bent.
Yes, light bends with
gravity in acceleration.
I'm going to run right
back to the chalkboard
and then he solved the Theory of
Relativity so images you know.
And when I was bopping around in
the Mission District in early days
in San Francisco there was
a bookstore in Spanish,
a Spanish-language
bookstore and it was one,
I couldn't afford these things
so I just walked by them
and I saw this big volume of a
burgundy leather covered book
with gilded gold dusty pages
and it said Federico Garcia Lorca
[foreign language spoken] complete
works so I picked it up and
it weighed like 10 kilos
and it was just beautiful
images and I had
to just follow as best as I could.
>> Let me just ask you one
final question which gets back
to Jane McAuliffe's introduction
and the Witter Bynner Foundation.
Part of its mission is
to "Help expand awareness
for the positive effects
of poetry on society".
I wonder if you can
both talk about the ways
that you work towards
that aim in your poems.
>> Yeah, everything is about that,
really when it comes down to it.
I mean that's the whole purpose
right, to bring knowledge,
to bring what's happening in the
world to audience, to the readers
so that the readers can leave
themselves in their mind
for that time that
they're transfixed
by the poem, moved by the poem.
They can learn from it.
They can understand something,
develop empathy, do something good
in the world, get active,
get up and move
because something has
happened in reading that poem.
That's why people remember lines
because it helps them to cope.
It helps them to move forward.
It helps them to grow.
So I think it's all about that
really when it comes down to it.
>> I guess so many beautiful
things, so many beautiful things
and you know I was thinking
of playing with the unknown
and I was also thinking
of one of the early,
one of the ancient
Chinese writers, essayists
and who said there were five
pleasures of literature,
the five pleasures of literature.
It's back in probably 300 A.D.
around there and so Lu Chi writes
about the five pleasures of writing
and literature and he says and one
of them is to task the void
and I was stumped by that.
That one of the delights of
writing is to task the void
and I couldn't break
the word task down.
I mean tasking the void, the void.
Everything is interconnected
atomically, sub-atomically.
That's kind of a kindergarten
interpretation
of the void and then to task it.
How do we task totality
if we're in totality, so,
which is unexplainable except
for Einstein [laughter].
That's it right there,
so, exactly so what again?
[ Inaudible Response ]
We're in the portions of, exactly.
How's that?
Making the what?
>> Making the [inaudible] yeah.
>> Making the place?
>> Opening it up.
>> Opening it up, making it,
yeah making it, making a place
and that's the answer you see.
[ Inaudible Response ]
You know so I couldn't figure
that out and then that's it,
making the place for the
unexplainable, multiple forces
of the universe of
which we're all one.
>> I mean I look at a story
like the big [inaudible]
in and out of [inaudible].
We get little bits
of it over your life.
People give you this advice
or tell you this story
because it means this.
You hear this form
because you need this.
You pick up the song
You go to this performance because,
a little bit at a time and hopefully
by the time when you mature
[inaudible] we have a handle
of what's going on
around us, you know.
We're moving through it.
We're understanding what's
happening and then we have something
to give back because we can
start to fill in that story.
The story of culture
inextricable from one another,
culture builds stories
slowly builds culture.
They change and transform depending
on the generations [inaudible]
but that sphere is
still there to draw upon
and so there's always
that return, yeah.
>> Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Well speaking of story we've
come to the moment in this story
of our event in which we honor
our new Witter Bynner Fellow
by presenting her with her check
for $10,000 and we have to do this.
The chief of staff of the Library
of Congress, Robert Newland I'd
like to call him to
the stage please.
Allison [inaudible] stand up.
>> Okay [laughter]
>> Yes, yes, yes.
[ Applause ]
So on behalf of the
Library of Congress I would
like to celebrate our 2016 Witter
Bynner Fellow Allison Hedge Coke,
please stand.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, thank you.
There are books which you
can buy and get signed.
There's also a wonderful
reception courtesy
of the Witter Bynner Foundation
and we ask that you please fill
out a survey form and hand
to me or put it up here
so we can know how this event was.
We hope to see you soon.
Juan Felipe will be giving his final
event on April 13th so please come
and check out our website
and thanks a lot.
>> Thank you
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov